Việt Nam còn nóng hơn cả SA mạc Sahara
các bạn nghe không lầm đâu
hôm qua rất nhiều nơi ở Việt Nam xảy Ra nắng nóng đầu mùa
Hà Nội có lúc lên đến 38 độ
nho quan Ninh Bình 39 độ
nhiều điểm đo vượt 41 độ như là quỳ châu đô lương
riêng trạm Tây Hiếu xấp xỉ 42 độ
tại Hà Tĩnh thì Hương Sơn và hương Khê cũng nóng trên 40 độ
nắng nóng cũng mở rộng xuống Chung Chung bộ
với Đà Nẵng 39 độ
Quảng Ngãi 38 độ và khu vực Sơn Hòa Đắk Lắk đạt 39 độ
đáng chú ý là ngày hôm qua
nơi nóng nhất ở SA mạc Sahara
cũng chỉ đo được là khoảng 36 độ
như vậy
rất nhiều nơi ở Việt Nam còn nóng hơn cả SA mạc Sahara
trong lịch sử thì tương Dương ở Nghệ An đã lập kỷ 6
nóng nhất Việt Nam với 44,2 độ C
và liệu trong mùa hè năm nay
có địa phương nào phá được kỷ 6 này hay không
thì không AI biết trước được
nhưng nắng nóng như thế này ở Việt Nam vẫn chưa là gì
so với mức nhiệt độ 57 độ C tại thung lũng tử thần của Mỹ
mức nhiệt độ 44,2 độ C kỷ 6 ở Việt Nam
mà tại SAO thực tế lại cảm nhận nóng hơn như thế
rất nhiều bởi vì đơn giản
nhiệt độ đo tại trạm khí tượng là
nhiệt độ đo ở bóng râm cách mặt đất khoảng 1,5m
còn nếu mà đo ở nhiệt độ ở ngoài mặt đường
thì sẽ phải lên đến tầm 60 đến 70 độ C
và thậm chí còn có thể dán được cả trứng nữa